je demande c'est squeeze et aujourd'hui
on se retrouve sur borderlands numéro un
pas de deux en compagnie de deux mois de
croquis de moi de moi je vote non
et alors pourquoi ni sur le 1 parce que
on est pauvre nom soit parce que en fait
tout le monde fait les deux sur le 2 ce
qui n'est pas plus mal d'ailleurs
bon c'est déjà dit dans la vidéo de
croquis mais pour ce qui a manqué aux
ficelles de craxi d'ailleurs cliquez sur
notation si vous n'avez pas vu celle de
croque si c'est juste la mission d'avant
celle ci en gros on est sur le 1 parce
qu'on s'est dit ben y'a vieil habit boys
et diablesses cnaf qui font en net repli
sur le 2e alors nous on va faire un
petit truc sur le rhin on va se faire un
petit mot de code 3 kills sans forcément
faire des vidéos sur le rhin puis l'a vu
que c'était une grosse mission bien
grasse avec bien des moindres se dit
qu'on est d'en faire une vidéo et ces
personnes il fera sûrement plaisir et
que voilà toutes les infos dans l'autre
vidéo et voilà il ya plein de choses et
voilà voilà
et l'on visionné tout le monde et c'est
partit alors en gros là le but c'est de
récupérer une clé en fait je crois qu'on
va devoir twitter oui oui c'est un
problème que la première fois qu'on
était
oui oui ou alors parce que précision on
est déjà venu ici mais on était niveau
genre 12 et il fallait être niveau au
moins 15 ou 16 et on se faisait gang
bang mais genre mais jean jaurès était
l'un des trois héros de manga mais
[ __ ] de plein de violent là c'était
vraiment hard et la police ce qui est
sale et balises même là ils font alors
les gros la balance élections heureux
juste la merde
plus de bouclier à moi non plus la
consumer longtemps sur [ __ ]
heureusement j'ai pris des petites
trousses de soin et bien j'ai une petite
technique après avec mathorel va mais
très comme ça tu te re from peu de biba
mémoire du gameplay des principes du jeu
c'est un peu comme rapide je me souviens
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment comme le 2
1 c'est juste les graphismes et les
classes qui change pour les quêtes aussi
mais sinon dans le fond c'est la même
j'adore j'adore les gros jeux les looks
je sais absolument rien j'ai mis un gros
qui tire bien épais coiffure violente
claque multinationales voilà ça c'est
fait reprend un peu de vie avec ma tour
elle pendant qu'allié dans deux secondes
l'est plus donc des péjoces voilà c'est
bien trop tard
alors oui alors petite précision manger
le soldat si jamais on n'a même pas dit
dans ma vidéo chez le soldat mois donc
en gros j'ai la tourelle et puis toi tu
as la sirène alors la sirène c'est dans
le 2 pour ceux qui connaissent que le 2
c'est le même pouvoir que l'assassin au
final que le mec au final l'assassin qui
sema invisible dans c'est un petit peu
le même principe vous mettez invisible
si vous mettez un coup de hanche ou
physique donc bon là elle fait à la
pomme decaux noël pote avec sa marque
comme ça là
et sinon tu aimes et dictaphone ouais en
fait je me fais une hamelin a atteint
ckoi et dégueulasse mais elle est plus
là didon bon attends je vais reprendre
mon truc d'état j'ai bien fait de
prendre des traits à wayne tu vois tu
vois tu va carrément et puis en plus
j'ai pas encore récupéré ma tour elle
donc voilà j'ai pas trop où on va mon
niveau je serai doucement mais sûrement
en plus les laissant obtenir cette
libération je vous adore aïe aïe je me
fais quand même dans le côté c'est quand
il y en a un qui pète un clip est où il
est bien fort lui il est bien forte
chute un batteur et un le virolainen
mayol c'est toi qui l'a tuée je suis deg
regard de turenne il se plaît truc de
fou trop mal
la tourelle qui sert à rien 2 excuse moi
excusez moi comme ça on broie un peu vis
aussi voilà alors moi je précise ici je
ramasse tout s'est donc pas pour faire
mon gros ninja à mettre un doigt dans
les fesses à crocs pas du tout c'est
simplement qu'après je revend aux
distributeurs et ça nous fait en fait
dessouder sont atteints nous fait des
sous pour tous les deux et ça divise en
deux aya un club trap eye va donner une
mission lui si je me souviens bien mais
je la prends voilà voilà bon par contre
on reste sur la mission qu'on est en
retard
o le pistolet à 40 euros je le veux je
veux je le veux je le veux direct celui
que j'avais ce que j'ai pris non celui
que j'ai pris pour épistolaire très ça
que j'ai pris un à 41 atteint mangeant
mais on a foncé sur moi j'ai eu un
pistolet cadence de tir dégueulasse
celui que j'ai pris à non à wayne ont
mission dégueulasse en fait ils sont
tous légaux
ok bon compte il continue on continue à
développer ici c'est super chaud c'est
parti mais s'il vient vers l'avenir
sa taille ou son tu vas voir me dire ça
au nom mais n'ont rien à craindre
alors ce qu'on vous dit d'impression de
vidéos l'espèce de trucs on n'avait pas
du tout à s'élever l'attend je crois
juste items bleus pendant que très peu
parler d'elle mais telle fille mini
server attends je vais dans la fosse au
maintien voyage j'ai trouvé une cache
d'armes a avec moi j'étais des ennemis
à défaut c'est il faut atteindre le but
c'est quoi sa croix axa web et que tu
perdes voilà quel bordel comique elmi
bouh
alors il faut les ou maintenant à baba
faut suivre le chemin je pense par
contre a plus beaucoup de vieilles s'est
trouvé une perf que j'ai pas dis alors
ninja pour l'expression c'est quand il y
en a dit m et comprend tout de suite
sans même le laisser à son pote en mode
gros bâtards ça ça veut dire ninja donc
si je dis je te les ninjas cette viande
rouge tous les volets quoi bon je lis
prétendre que tu sois la gt40 les
munitions jeter ninja ninja cuse web tu
vas à gauche voilà le chemin pas
indiquée est ici tu vois plein de
munitions
voilà il ya là il ya une quête pour moi
avec des armes de dents voilà salut
voila
au revoir dans la journée il a une arme
pour toi à l'intérieur qui est
dégueulasse voilà salut boys ariel je
récupère toutes les grandes marques
comme ça tu es carottes genre des yeux
des gueux dégueulasse et de toute façon
j'ai déjà tout mais grenade donc je
t'emmerde à la temps je me bats toi même
scénar non c'est leur gardien
ah ben oui on aurait pu à lamballe et on
peut aller en vacances
les petits les petits comme ça ils font
ils sont pas très fort et plein coeur à
gauche
bon appui sur 7,4 de 2,8 c'est le groupe
et j'ai mené j'ai trouvé une cata jeudi
date où j'ai trop mal à ok salut toi
voilà si j'avais parlé des balles comme
ça au moins ça s'est fait au oui non
match nul 9-9 et oui voilà ça c'est fait
c'est fait ça sans en halimi c'est
plutôt une bonne chose qu'on a puisque
quand on va mal il met sa tourelle on se
protège derrière ou sinon à quand moi je
vais mal bon c'est un peu bâtard la
salle être le brésilien quand moi je
vais mal je me mets un bris et je taille
tout simplement va si bien
rien n'est pas là alors ici mon gars
c'est archi du rawyl a salué le voilà
oui plus gros on s'inquiète plus gros
poisson grave charbon gaz pas normal ça
on est un peu de shit et quoi la neige
le week end
le soir elle franchement si tu meurs je
vais t'en vouloir souffler m6 fait pas
attendre encore à déballer sans dire et
tout donc aulas l'a violée en fait pas
attendre c'est quoi je vais aller voir
mec c'était le boss [ __ ] ce truc
c'était le boss m'ont bien d'intendance
pas possible non non non il y avait un
autre chaussure impossible mais presque
possible c'est aussi notre match on a
tôt fait qu'on continue comme on a trois
fois plus galérer dans la mise en avant
caustique 2 avril j'avoue je vous je
vous évite à tout prix bah oui avec el
battar quoi à temps mais non mais avec
du cash n'y avait pas d'armes ah bah
quand on voit la super league cependant
avec ouvrir ça et prendre ça je suis sur
lie à un gros mot ce qu elle pendant
c'est toi mais c'est pour accéder un
nouveau truc en fait ça on a fait un
buzz seulement en fait les munitions à
son dire à mon avis tu es chaque
candidat chaque type de créature et
chaque bosse à son à son gros coup de
pub les joies que je crois qu'on lui eut
trop tard en chef pas mal je crois que
là pour le coup son point faible c'était
à le feu parce que la [ __ ] c'était
violent mais alors là les d'une force
mais c'était vraiment changer quoi et
bien maintenant c'est clair au lieu
d'aller aux rapports on va voir le club
track
j'ai même pas les jeunes les salaires il
y a
à temps parce que là on est venu dans
l'antre de l'un de leurs revenus liée au
retard je me perds c'est tellement bien
fait grand que c'est bien quand tu joues
à ça c'est ouais c'est bien espacé radio
[ __ ] il ya un trou lui qui me l'a
encore alors la bonne journée connue
ouais aller amusez vous bien à la fédé
toi jean lui résiste vachement clame tu
vois alors que je me souviens c'est à
gbagbo 70 à chaque fois être au channel
il a pris trop cher le pôle
ouah je prend cher à t'en vas là on va
en fait les plus rapides et vers la fin
là pour la mission du club je sais pas
du tout le truc se déclare alors attends
sur select au pire il regarde par ici et
là j'en ai parlé ça c'est fait ça c'est
fait il faut trouver sur une petit kit
de réparation roi ce mignon à chercher
assez mignons les aides
ouais ça doit être vrai s'ils sont
mignons tous les ennemis envie ça se
fait rare aïe c'est de l'autre côté sans
marcher qu'avec la carte mais en fait
c'est pas le sag étaient en fait cutting
la sierra leone vise là à mon avis doit
être pas loin d'ici bas tarifs du
travail et non attends il doit être au
dessus
voilà là bas il voulait jamais je les
tue la base il vient on va aller réparer
ce aujourd'hui claptraps vient de faire
sa wii sont mignons comme tu l'as où oui
je lis je lui qui je ne le quittera kit
de réparation on rapporte donc parfait
et françois pillou mais pas juste en
dessous là vers la droite
attends attends [ __ ] de l'est où on
l'entend crier en plus c'est horrible je
suis récompensé passe en dessous
voilà un parfait oui il va vous donner
des [ __ ] d'armes et où je crois une
caisse une porte rouge pas quoi générer
ce jeu c'est quelques risques qu il est
nul à chier
non il ya des grenades il ya des
grenades de sympathiques moi je trouve
des grenades à 40 je vous je les veux
bien mais déjà scellé même prendre un
truc de gros note aussi l'étude japon
plier des grâces le bouclier il est au
cutter 1 et les filles et moi j'aime
bien mais j'avoue il fait des dégâts de
feu quand ils les tuent la vie parallèle
et pas mal de l'épaule attend que pop
merci je te serre la main derrière je te
laisse le maté les fesses vas-y sur un
patois qui pète un câble bon allez même
infondées ou bah faut refaire du tout en
fait chaque fois les hourras pourquoi
voilà on est venu 12e
brad un jeu faire explorer s'annexer
d'un club trappe il est hélas assez là
bas je crois encore poussé ici là à
droite
d'accord on bouge ça vous laisse et
poissy ouais c'est la scène est venue de
là on aime on est monté ici voilà pour
cette année elle jouit goncourt cette
fille c'est incroyable qu'elle fait là
bas je fais n'importe quoi n'importe
quoi c'est incroyable attends je vais
juste devant les trucs qui servent à aa
uniquement aussi en fait alors je viens
de cahus a aussi atteint jeunes pistolet
qui marchent que dame qui te gêne
pistolets des batailles l'a42 dégâts ce
pistolet actuelle que 21 où est le
problème
pourquoi j'ai une arme bleus avec le
truc ah ouais d'accord
maintenant on va mettre l'autre trick on
va mettre ça là que j'ai levé la déjà à
jeunes qu est ce qu a do wah mais ça
c'est une amélioration que tu as eue
t'inquiète ahmed a put un fait utiliser
utilisent leur [ __ ] ça déchire ça te
fait le plein de des marathons
mais ce n'est pas la récompense de
claptraps c'est possible en fait je
pense qu'ils en faisaient
ah ouais c'est tout cas pris la roue
c'est la date où cannes doit écouter les
gens je pense qu'on va on va s'arrêter
là puisque ça fait quand même vingt
bonnes minutes à tout troué ce qu'on
préfère c'est soit on fait une vidéo
juste après qui sera sur nos deux
chaînes pour pouvoir on verra plus tard
plus tard dans le jeu de manière vous
entretenir tout vous retrouverez ray du
board à la fin et sur sa chaîne sur
l'honneur aussi et sur la chaîne
secondaires aussi tu vois moi et puis qu
à une heure du matin
enfin vous même de petit best-of why not
[ __ ] salut au salon 50e
j'te fuck un truc est ce ce trio 2 quand
tu parles de tes vidéos toi tu fais pas
semblant
j'étais grenade
j'ai des repères concrets